as part of our hashtag out green me
challenge we are asking you to show us
how much you know about our changing
planet we've got a little quiz on our
website for you nate burleson and his
daughter mia already tested his wife and
she aced it okay
oh it's always fun to test your family
members isn't it i wanted to see the
full the full video
nate and family yeah yeah
online earth day is 52 years old you
know it started because we woke up to
the idea that the earth was not so big
that we couldn't affect it we could hurt
it i kind of hope at some point we get
to
a stage where you don't really have to
think about earth day because we kind of
got it figured you know we're no longer
harming and in decline we're kind of
we're stable and that day's far in the
future yeah we call it utopia it's the
hope it's the dream no seriously i mean
i hate to be a debbie downer here but we
got to get moving yeah we've got to get
moving we've got to get moving on this
too we want to take a quiz if you'd like
to take the quiz yourself and test your
family members because that's always fun
you know to
have a little rivalry cbsnews.com
earth day is where you head your local
news is next